Narrator: Tonight,
powerhouse investor
Ashton Kutcher
returns to the Tank.
In the Tank, entrepreneurs
seek an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
We all love our pets
like our children.
That's why I started Petnostics.
Narrator: If the Sharks hear
a great idea...
High five, bro.
...they'll invest
their own money...
♪ I like to win ♪
Narrator: ...and fight
each other for a deal.
I was crowned
the king of QVC.
He crowned himself.
Let him get his offer out.
Why would I want him
to get his offer out?
Narrator: But the entrepreneurs
must get the full amount
they're asking for
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
Herjavec: We're gonna be old
and gray by the time we make
any real money.
-But this is just the beginning.
You're a cockroach
in this space. Sorry.
Narrator:
Who are the Sharks?
They're self-made
business experts worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a shrewd venture capitalist
who made his fortune
selling a children's
educational company
for over $4 billion.
Robert Herjavec, son of
an immigrant factory worker,
founded one of
the world's preeminent
cyber-security firms.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
more than 400 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in sales.
Mark Cuban,
esteemed billionaire tech mogul
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
And Ashton Kutcher,
the renowned film
and television star,
is also a formidable investor.
His multiple
venture-capital funds
have successful investments
in high-profile companies
like Uber, Airbnb, and Skype.
First into the Tank
is an innovation
to ensure the good health
of your loved ones.
♪♪
Hi.
My name is Stephen Chen.
This here is Austin.
I am the founder of Petnostics,
and I'm here today
seeking $300,000 in exchange
for 10% of my company.
We all love our pets
like our children,
and it's important to monitor
their health regularly.
Unlike children, though,
our pets cannot talk to us.
And that's why I started
Petnostics.
Petnostics allows you to check
your pet's health instantly
by analyzing your dog
or cat's urine
with your smart phone.
So let's pretend that this
blue liquid is Austin's urine.
So, here we have Austin's sample
in the Petnostics cup,
which has a special lid
that's integrated
with the same
chemical test strips
that vets use
in their clinics.
Once you get your pet's urine
in our cup,
simply screw on the lid...
and flip the cup over.
These test pads
will then change colors
depending on your pet's health.
And out app will scan the cup
and analyze the color changes,
telling you
about possible health issues --
anything from diabetes
and urinary tract infections
to whether your pet
is properly hydrated.
Here you can see
the results of the test,
and you can easily save
and share with your vet.
With Petnostics,
at a fraction of the cost
of a vet visit
and from the comfort
of your own home,
you really can check
your pet's health instantly.
So, Sharks, Austin and I
would like to know if...
you're in.
Urine.
Get it?
[ Laughs ]
I have samples here
for you today,
and I'll be happy to answer
any questions you may have.
That is the cutest dog.
Good boy, Austin.
[ Laughter ]
You can grab one.
Thank you.
Hey, Austin!
Rescue dog?
-He is a rescue dog.
-Of course.
Hey.
-Thank you, sir.
-Thank you.
Kutcher: Uh, Steve,
can I ask you a question?
Yes.
How do you capture
the urine sample?
[ Laughs ]
That's a good question.
That's a very good question.
So, pet parents know that pets
relieve themselves on schedule.
So for me and Austin,
when I'm walking him,
I know
when he's about to pee.
I just get the cup behind him,
and I'm able to get the sample
that way.
You have to have the cup
under your dog
and letting your dog piss
in your hand and the cup
to capture the sample?
They give you a glove.
-[ Laughs ]
-For pet parents that have
a little bit more trouble
collecting the urine,
we have the Petnostics
Urine Collector.
[ Laughter ]
It's a little ladle
with an extendable handle.
Cuban:
It's like a selfie stick.
So, for female dogs or --
Yeah.
And so when Austin --
If there's a female dog
and they squat,
you can just kind of, you know,
get underneath there...
-[ Groans ]
-...and get the urine that way.
How much do you actually need
to capture
for the diagnostics to work?
Just a little teeny bit, yeah,
for the strips to change color.
What does it cost the consumer
to do all this stuff
and get all the paraphernalia
for pee collection?
We retail the cups for $10.
What does it cost you?
It costs me $2 right now
to make one of these.
How low do you think
you could get it at volume?
Um, we think we can get our cost
down to about 90 cents.
It's a one-time lab, right?
-It's a one-time-use cup.
-Okay.
How many cups have you sold
and to how many customers?
So, cups,
we've sold about 10,000 cups.
-What?
-Well, in what period of time?
-When did you start?
-We started in April 2014.
How have you sold?
So, we've sold right now
just through our website
and through local retail stores
in Southern California.
That's very impressive.
And so the leading vets,
they liken our product
to a check-engine light.
You know, seeing,
oh, there's something wrong,
potentially, under the hood,
then you still
have to have the expert,
the vet, take care of it.
What's your background?
What did you do
before you did this?
So, um,
I did industrial engineering
at the University of Michigan,
and I got my MBA from Harvard.
Stephen,
do you have the original IP?
Yeah.
So we have four issued patents
around this technology already,
and --
-What is the technology?
-On what?
So, on this
all-in-one embodiment
of the strip
and then this cup format,
and also, most importantly,
is the algorithm
that we use to color-calibrate
for the strip
and, um, the app
to recognize the colors.
Okay. But you're just taking
what's already available
-with the strips...
-Exactly.
...and then
you're simplifying it
to a consumer-friendly
product.
Our patents do cover,
um, a wide range of uses.
And so, you know,
a logical next extension
of this product
is in the human market.
Kutcher: To me, the biggest
barrier to entry on this thing
is collecting the sample
from the dog.
Like, I really don't
want to do that.
Now, I have two dogs.
If one of my dogs
is really sick,
I would -- I would actually
do this on behalf of my dog.
But I've seen things
in the human space
where you can take a blood
sample, really, really simple,
and I would think
on behalf of a pet,
it'd be a lot easier
to just give one little prick
on the pet,
take a tiny blood sample,
and do that test
than be underneath the dog,
trying to collect
a urine sample.
Vets don't generally do
the blood tests at home
because pet parents
don't like to prick
the animal or the pet
and get blood that way.
So, Stephen,
I'm still trying to understand
where the value add
to the consumer is.
Is it a cost saving
over going to a vet?
Initially, it is
proof of concept that we have.
We thought
the check-engine light
was gonna be
a very valuable proposition.
Well, the difference is
a check-engine light is passive.
Mm-hmm.
In your case,
there's got to be an action
that caused me to go
stick my hand under my dog
while he's peeing.
We realize that the impetus
to put it under
is if the vet tells you
to do so.
So it's vet-driven?
We definitely
want to go the vet route.
The problem is my vet
wants me to bring my animal in
as many times as I possibly can.
Yeah, yeah.
You have to do that, too, right?
Why's my vet gonna give me
this really convenient thing?
Say, "I don't
have to charge you anymore.
Here. Take this cup."
Yeah. See, I think
it's a consumer play.
Herjavec:
Look, I admire the fact
that you've sold 10,000.
I'm still amazed by that,
but I'm not sold
on the business model.
Vets want to make more money,
not less money.
I believe in this product,
but I also have to really
believe in a very clear
distribution channel.
Mm-hmm.
I think you're early.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
O'Leary:
Walks us through the numbers.
What's the revenue gonna be
for this calendar year?
Um, we're projecting $200,000
in sales this calendar year.
Okay, so you're not making
any money yet.
So, next year,
we're projecting, hopefully,
$400,000 in sales with these
new specific-disease tests.
That market makes up
590 million tests
that potentially can be done.
But it's not clear yet,
Stephen,
what the go-to-market
distribution strategy is.
We're talking about vets,
direct sales online,
maybe retail,
if you can find enough margin.
That's not clear yet.
These are all
to be determined, right?
Yes.
There's a bit of risk
in your deal
in terms of
what's gonna happen.
And you're a little
prerevenue-ish.
You know, what I love
about "Shark Tank" deals
is when it's already proven
what the channel's gonna work.
I pour $300,000 on it.
It's just like gasoline on fire.
It explodes.
You're not there yet.
Okay.
What are the -- You said there
were four patents that you had.
The patents cover
any specimen --
like, specific-use cases.
And so if it's the human market,
we can also do water testing,
milk and dairy testing.
There's a lot of different
applications --
But it's all strip --
It's all strip, yes.
That's the key, right?
I'm very involved
on the human side.
I've got investments
in a company called Biomeme
that does blood analysis.
My point is that being
strip-driven,
I think,
will have a life cycle.
I just don't see it
as a long-term life cycle.
I see that as a problem.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Kutcher: I think you have
something interesting,
and I think there's a market
for this.
And there are real channels
to get to pet owners
that care about their pets
that little bit more.
Mm-hmm.
My biggest concern
is still around
the very first question
that we had around collection.
I think
that you're gonna be disrupted
by a bunch
of other platforms
that can do the same thing
that you do
without the messiness
of having to do a urine sample.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
I thought Ashton
was going to make you an offer,
'cause you know, Ashton,
you can sell a lot
before somebody else comes out
with something better.
I think I can get this out there
to the consumer.
I try to skate
to where the puck is going,
not to where the puck is.
And I don't think that that's
where the puck is gonna be.
O'Leary: There's technology,
and then there's
distribution risk.
I'm more concerned
about distribution risk --
how you blow
this thing out
so you sell
a few million dollars of it.
I want to reflect that
in my offer.
I'll do the $300,000
for 15%.
Mm. Okay.
Herjavec: Interesting.
Wow.
Kutcher: You know, Kevin,
I've watched this show a lot.
Your deals
always have ratchets, levers,
you have the some royalties,
some plug-in hooking --
No, I'm really good
at that.
I'm the most creative shark
in structure.
Are you gonna ask him
why he likes this one?
You can call it creative.
I'm learning
what not to do.
I call it founder abuse,
but you can call it creative.
I'm really curious
about why you're offering
a straight equity deal
on this.
I do them occasionally,
but I think this is a play
on trying to figure out
which channel works
and then pouring
gasoline on it,
because at this point,
he doesn't even know
how he's gonna sell it.
So there's no point
in ratcheting anything.
There's nothing
to ratchet.
If there was, trust me,
I would do it.
I think it's interesting.
I like your four patents.
I've sold a lot of products
over the last 18 years.
And I have seen so many people
spend so much on their pets.
And they want to make sure
that they're okay.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
$300,000 for 20%.
I don't really see this
as a QVC television product.
Oh, QVC would crush it.
QVC would crush it.
Yeah, QVC, retail, online --
everything.
I think we all do that.
And you want him to pay
an extra 5% in equity for that?
That's not worth it.
I think I'm worth it.
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Stephen has two offers
on the table
for his pet-health indicator,
Petnostics.
You've got Lori --
$300,000 for 20%.
She's bringing QVC, retail,
all kinds of things.
She thinks she's worth
an extra 5%.
Kevin's in $300,000 at 15%.
What are you gonna do,
Stephen?
I know Lori
will bring the retail side.
Um, Kevin will really bring
the veterinary clinic side.
I will.
But I challenge you.
I want to do both.
I would do both, too,
though.
But, you know,
this queen of QVC thing,
I've got news.
I went on QVC recently.
-Oh, no.
You ready?
This is gonna hurt Lori
a little.
In 3 minutes and 40 seconds,
I sold $500,000 of wine.
I was crowned the king of QVC
that moment.
He crowned himself
the king of QVC.
No one has ever sold
that much wine ever
from a single brand
on QVC.
The point is, anybody can do QVC
and sell a lot of stuff.
What are you gonna do,
Stephen?
I guess, Lori,
can I ask you one question?
Would you consider
$300,000 for 15%?
Oh, equaling Kevin's offer,
Lori.
I feel, at 15%, you know,
as much as I really do love this
and I think it's a great product
and my thought would be --
Queen, come here for a second.
The king is speaking.
Ugh.
If you want to split the deal,
I'll do 50/50 for 20%.
20%.
This is because you didn't move
fast enough in some ways.
20%...
50/50 -- king and queen.
-You had 15%.
-20%...
Queen and joker.
It's the only offer
on the table now.
I'm in.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much.
Thanks, man.
Good presentation.
And I get the dog.
Thank you, Lori.
Thank you so much.
-Good idea.
-Thank you so much.
Come on, Austin.
Let's go.
Cuban:
Good job, Austin.
-Congratulations, Stephen.
-Come on. Here we go.
-Good job, guys.
-Cute.
-Aww.
Here we go.
Come on.
Greiner: Aww,
that dog is the cutest.
I'm feeling good, I think.
To get a deal with Lori
and Kevin,
they both bring a good balance
in terms of where we want to go
and where we are seeing success
right now.
And so I am very, very happy
that we got a deal.
♪♪
Welcome to paradise.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I've invited
my favorite entrepreneurs
to Cabo San Lucas in Mexico.
Tom + Chee, Pipsnacks,
Villy Custom, Daisy Cakes,
Ry's Ruffery,
Cousins Maine Lobster,
and our newcomers, PiperWai.
I've asked each of my businesses
to think of areas
where they need help
and where they could contribute.
We're here because
we want to learn
how to grow
our online sales.
Lobster online is probably
a hard thing to sell.
So maybe focus
on the holidays
and just make lobster
the ultimate gift.
I want to improve the bike
imagery on our website.
We just want to know
how you've dealt
with this
overnight success.
Lomac: Well, I think you have
to stay true to your values
and make sure you never
compromise your product.
Ribner: For newcomers like us,
this is invaluable,
learning about the challenges
of other entrepreneurs
and ways that we can be
successful going forward.
Jen:
This doesn't happen to everyone,
and to be able to learn
while you're in paradise,
that's priceless.
Who's ready to go
to the beach?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Corcoran: I'm so proud of each
of my entrepreneurs.
They all work like crazy
to make their dreams come true.
Ryan: When I started my company,
I only had about $900 in sales.
It's been three years,
and we made
over $1.8 million in sales.
Since getting my deal, we've
done $4.3 million in sales.
We've now done $32 million,
and we have 36 locations open.
Corcoran:
Before "Shark Tank,"
sales for these 7 businesses
were $1.7 million.
Combined sales
are now $62 million.
This is our third retreat,
which qualifies as a tradition.
[ Cheering ]
Working with these
young businesses
is probably the most satisfying
work I've ever done.
You get to share their joys
and their pitfalls
and you feel like
you've had a real hand
in making their dream
a reality.
It's a great feeling to bring my
entrepreneur family together,
and I can't wait
to do it again.
All: Thank you, Barbara!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a functional and fashionable
music accessory.
Hi. I'm Keir Dillon.
And I'm Sheen Moaleman.
Our company is Frends,
and we're seeking $1 million
in exchange
for 7.6% of our company.
Over the past decade,
headphones have evolved
from electronic devices to
lifestyle-defining accessories.
Yet, as an accessory, the design
language isn't fashionable.
Nothing that would excite
the female consumer
the same way a new handbag
or a stunning necklace could.
We set out
to create headphones
that would be more than
just a way to listen to music,
but a fashion accessory
that women would love to wear.
Update your look
with the simple twist of a cap.
Frends offers a collection
of interchangeable caps
that allow you to accessorize
your headphones
to reflect your personal style
and match your every mood.
Inspired from the runway,
a new collection of caps
is released each season,
so your Frends
will always stay on trend.
Sharks, if you know style
is deeper than clothes,
then you will love
your Frends.
And to prove it,
we've even got some samples
for you guys to check out
and listen
that I will pass out
right now.
So...
Thank you.
Very cool.
Greiner: Pretty.
What do you think?
They're really pretty.
How much are they?
We sell the smaller ones
for $150
and the larger ones
for $200.
Herjavec:
So, Keir, you've got a value
of roughly $12 million
on the company.
You must have a ton of sales.
Um, we have
a ton of demand.
And that's why we are here
meeting with you guys.
Sales and demand
are not the same thing.
Uh, last year we did
$2.9 million in sales.
We were on a target
for $6 million.
But distribution channels?
Nordstrom, Bloomingdales online,
Anthropologie online.
So, you did $2.9 million.
You thought you would do
$6 million.
What went wrong
or what happened?
When we first launched,
we were lucky to have
the two largest
consumer-electronic retailers
approach us and say,
"We want to carry you guys."
-Apple and Best Buy?
-Both.
This is back in 2012
that we launched.
What did you in 2013 when you
were in Apple and Best Buy?
$2.5 million.
How much did you make
on the $2.5 million you did?
We lost $1.3 million.
-You lost --
-So, you said --
Sorry, Lori.
You lost $1.3 million?
-Correct.
-Why?
So we shipped into Apple.
They had a hold-back clause.
So, you shipped in $2.4 million
worth of inventory.
So now all the capital
is exposed and you only get paid
on every single piece
that you have ticking through.
Was it a consignment deal?
Yes.
Consignment is inventory
goes on the wall.
You only get paid
when they get paid.
Correct.
-The rest comes back.
-Correct.
-Bad outcome.
-How did you absorb that loss?
We've been doing
convertible note since.
And how much
have you raised?
Uh, $1.5 million
of convertible notes.
Once we got that product back,
that was pretty much
end-of-life goods
that we still sold out
through different --
So, you don't have it sitting
in the warehouse anymore?
No, it's all been allocated.
And we're constantly selling out
through our retailers
and even
on our e-commerce site.
Whatever we have is always gone.
So you can't keep up
with the demand...
-Exactly.
-...is what you're saying?
Cuban:
Let's just talk year to date.
Give us the picture there.
So, year to date,
uh, to April, $850,000.
And you're on track to do
about $2 million in revenue.
We're on track to do
$8.7 million this year.
Wait, so you think
your Christmas,
you're gonna have
a hockey stick in Christmas
and just go nuts?
-Correct.
How much did you do
last Christmas?
Uh, $1.2 million.
Okay, so $1.2 million
in a Christmas season.
And you think
that you're gonna do $6 million
this Christmas season?
-Correct.
Why?
Uh, we're launching
into, um,
mass fashion
with the new piece.
Well, where is it?
Are you gonna show it to us?
-Is that here?
-We have a sample here.
Oh, it's Bluetooth.
Moaleman:
It's 100% Bluetooth.
So, this is the controllers here
with the microphone.
Where are the earbuds?
The earbuds will be hanging
from the back?
Oh, I see.
It's cool.
It's an interesting
piece of, uh...
So, it's a necklace
that plays music.
Correct.
How much is the necklace
going to cost?
It's between
$300 and $500.
-Wow.
-$300 and $500 to the consumer.
That's expensive.
But what does it cost you?
$60.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So, your anticipation
around your lift
is around selling
that new product?
Part of it is, yeah.
But a lot of it is actually
just our normal distributions.
50% of our domestic sales
are still coming from our core.
Next year's sales --
What will they be
in your most
optimistic scenario?
$34 million.
-Okay.
-That's pretty optimistic.
I'm letting you
be optimistic.
Yes.
You have to put
a lot of steroids into this
to get it
to anything near that.
But anyways, what are you gonna
generate in free cash off that?
Um, $3 million,
but that's because
we're investing
all money back in.
You're a cockroach
in this space. Sorry.
In case
you didn't know that.
I know.
It's why we're here.
Very small.
Can you just give me
a simple number?
How much money
have you lost since inception?
$9 million.
-You've lost $9 million?
-Lost?
Wow.
I smell a scenario where you
go to zero, you know that?
I don't smell that,
but I appreciate that.
You're gonna run out of cash.
You're telling me
that you're gonna go
from $2.9 million
to $34 million in 12 months.
Yeah.
I'm out.
Kutcher: You know what?
I think you actually have
something pretty cool.
I think you're in
a really crowded space.
Your product is good,
but the problem is, the way
you explain your company,
it makes it seem like you
don't have your stuff together.
And I feel like
you're hiding something.
I don't know what it is.
But when I get that instinct,
I step out.
So I'm gonna pass.
I'm out.
Respect that.
I think, you know,
they look very nice.
But the problem for me
is I don't have confidence
in the way you're running
the business at all.
You've had a lot of issues
and you've lost a lot of money.
And I can't invest
in a company like that.
I'm out.
Yeah, they look nice,
but I don't know
if there's a big market,
especially at that price.
But you lost $9 million,
and you're still not
out of the woods.
And then your projection
to go to $34 million next year
would be astronomical
in that period of time.
I'm out.
Look, put aside
the losses, right?
That's not unusual in
a start-up company,
particularly
consumer electronics,
where you've had to pivot.
But from an investment
perspective,
it really comes down to
a million-dollar bet
on this, right?
Because this is gonna be
the foundation
for your 60% sales
in Christmas.
But it's just a singular bet.
And that's the part
I'm not comfortable with,
particularly
on the valuation.
And so I'm just
not convinced.
For those reasons, I'm out.
Thanks a lot, guys.
-Thanks.
-Appreciate it.
Thank you.
♪♪
If you're running
a responsible business
and you have debt,
that's okay.
Just own your debt and go...
-Be honest.
"...This is our debt,
this is what caused it,
and this is why it's all
gonna change in the future."
They have zero sales
of this thing.
There's no proof,
but that's the future?
I'm betting
on this piece of cardboard?
Narrator: Next up is a product
to make the most
of a common accessory.
♪♪
Sharks,
my name is Yashar Behzadi.
I'm the C.E.O. and co-founder
of popSLATE.
I'm here seeking $500,000
for 5% of my company.
With popSLATE,
we're gonna make you see
a whole new side
to your smartphone.
We all have one of these --
our most prized possession.
It's with us 24/7,
yet half the phone does nothing.
The back of the phone
is a tremendous piece
of real estate that's unclaimed
and that we want to own.
So, let me introduce you
to popSLATE.
popSLATE transforms
the back of your phone
into an always-on second screen.
Always on means
you have instant access
to what you want
when you want it.
Calendars, to-do lists,
recipes, maps, all at a glance.
It's never having
to fumble around anymore
for your boarding pass.
It's a 24/7 feed
of the information you want --
news or your favorite
sports scores.
With popSLATE, you can actually
customize your case instantly.
For me, I love popping
pictures of my son.
But this is just the beginning.
I need your help
to help grow the business
to get popSLATE on the back of
every single phone in the world.
So my question to you, Sharks,
is, who's in?
What happens
to the front of the screen?
So the front of the screen
is completely off,
and that's the beauty.
It saves you the hassle
of unlocking your phone,
digging around your apps
to get just a little bit
of information.
-Do we get samples?
-Yeah, absolutely.
It's not a dual screen?
I just want to be clear on that.
I can't have both on
at the same time?
Yes, you can.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
So we've customized those
for you.
There's Mr. Wonderful.
I like that.
Ashton, here.
So there's a button
on the side there.
If you hold down the button
for about a half a second,
it'll actually cycle
through images.
We've put
some of your favorite quotes
and some other images on there
for you guys.
How does it work?
Yeah, so it actually
is an e-paper screen,
so very much like you have
in your e-reader.
We've customized the screen
to make it super low power
and extra durable.
And it's connected wirelessly
to the phone via Bluetooth.
So you set up
that information
on the front-side application.
-That's right.
And then
the front-side application
delivers what you want
to the back side.
That's correct.
Tell me the biggest value point
to the consumer.
It saves you time, and we know
time is money, right?
So, for me,
when I'm running around my day
and just having
that basic information around
and being connected
is a huge saving for me.
And how much are you selling
each one for?
For $129 today.
And what's your cost
right now?
So the product you hold
in your hand today
-is about an $80 cost point.
-Wow.
But we have $41 quotes in hand
from the manufacturers
for volume production.
-$41?
-$41.
-And that's all in?
-That's all in, landed costs.
How much is the tooling
for each?
It's about $50,000
per tooling cycle.
So to tool up
for all the different phones
that are out there,
it's gonna be a lot of money.
That's right. So what we're
doing is focusing on iOS.
So luckily,
there's only two major models --
the iPhone 6 and 6 Plus.
How much money
have you lost,
and when do you think
you'll break even?
We've spent about $1.6 million
to date on the development.
When do you think
you'll break even?
We think we'll be
cash-flow-positive
in July of next year.
Herjavec:
I mean, I love technology.
I've been in the technology
business for a long time.
Sometimes I'm wildly right.
Sometimes I fall in love
with stuff and I'm wildly wrong.
It's very cool.
It's a beautiful design.
But I see this market moving,
actually, a different way.
I think where this is moving to
is a wearable technology.
We don't see it necessarily
competing with the wearables.
Wearables, I think,
have a different use case.
I think, for me,
the wearables are great
for small bits of information
like notifications,
things like that.
But this is a terrible
user experience.
Dick Tracy would argue
with you.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah, for me,
I see it going to a wearable.
I'm out.
The lock screen is really
your competition, right?
Because it's becoming
more and more powerful.
Notifications
are getting a lot stronger,
people are using the lock
screens for more things.
The problem
is you need to come up
with something new, different,
and exciting,
and this has the potential
to be that.
You know, if all of a sudden,
15 people you know walked in
and, boom,
there comes their picture,
or you're scrolling
through their picture
because they're
in the same room,
that's something different,
new, and exciting, right?
Absolutely. And I think we can
build exactly on your point.
So I think the real
great advantage of this
is the screen's always on.
So within context,
you can update the screen
to serve information.
So whether it's at a Mavs game
and giving you
relevant information...
Yeah.
...or it's walking into a store
and getting a coupon
or an advertisement
that you transact with.
It's a land grab.
You have to win.
It's a very binary space.
O'Leary: It's a land grab
for the accessory.
So you're left with what's left.
That's what I'm hearing.
If they put on
their own second screen.
Well, I think we're going
in that direction.
I think we're definitely
heading in that direction.
The problem that we have
and the reason why nobody
goes with a second screen
is just battery life, right?
Right. But this has
a battery-life issue too.
It's one week,
it's an e-reader,
it's low battery...
-I get that, but --
...which makes
a lot of sense.
As we debate
his business plan,
'cause that's
what we're doing...
-Wait, I have a question.
-...I'm looking at it,
saying to myself,
"I'll give you $500,000.
I get 5%. I'm the smallest guy
in the cap table."
You're welcome to give more.
You get a bigger space.
I have to pay
the full pop valuation
while we're still debating
what the direction is
because we don't agree,
and that's okay,
but that also reflects
the amount of risk in this deal.
I'm gonna look at it
from that perspective.
I don't think the risk/reward
is there for me.
I'm out.
Okay. Great.
Thank you.
Greiner:
I have a question for you.
To Ashton's point, are you
trying to drive the price down?
Yeah, we want to be
lower priced,
and I think our sweet spot
will be probably about $99.
I've sold million of dollars
of cellphone cases --
purely decorative.
It's a great market,
and obviously one that's going
to be growing and growing.
The down part for me
was always that you're never
catching up, right?
Cellphones are constantly
getting bigger and bigger.
It's something
you're always chasing after
because just as you get
a lot of inventory in,
it's like one hit, and then
you've got to be changing again.
And the tooling,
as we've talked about,
is extremely expensive.
I'm out.
And I appreciate that.
You're very much right.
We're very early
in what we're trying to do.
You've got two sharks left.
Okay, I like this platform.
I think your software side
is probably the most compelling
thing to me
because of your capacity
to use Bluetooth
and actually broadcast
whatever you want to program
into your application.
But what I'm afraid of
is that you have a dependency
on Apple because
you're iOS-only right now.
I think your price point's
a little bit too high.
I just can't get over
those hurdles.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay. Great.
Thank you.
See, to me, as this becomes
more multi-window
and lock screen
becomes smarter,
iOS is just gonna
keep on improving,
I don't think your product
becomes as critical
or as compelling.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Man, you did a very good job
today of explaining.
No, I really, really
appreciate it.
I know it's a new space, so we
have a lot of work ahead of us.
But I thank you for your time.
It's been wonderful.
-Thank you very much.
-Great. Thank you, guys.
-Appreciate it. Thank you.
-Bye.
You know,
I'm a little disappointed
that I didn't get the money,
but the feedback was wonderful.
I think everybody
had really good ideas.
It's a new space,
it's a new product,
you know, I think we have
some things to figure out.
That's a damn
good-looking case.
Oh, my God.
My name is Steve Watts.
And I'm his fiancée,
Angela Ferendo.
We live in Monarch Beach,
California.
And we are the founders
of Slyde Handboards.
I grew up in South Africa.
There's a huge surfing culture
over there.
As kids, we used to use
absolutely everything
to ride waves.
A lot of people look up
to surfers and want to be one,
but they don't have the time,
ability, or funds
to be able to do it.
Handboarding gives you
the thrill of surfing
without all the hassle.
Do they get a bicep leash,
as well?
Um...yep.
We're at a make-it-or-break-it
point for Slyde.
We've racked up
credit-card debt
and we've borrowed money
from friends and family.
The biggest thing is we took
all of our wedding money
that we had
and put it into the business.
If we don't get an investment
from the Sharks,
we won't be able
to get married,
we won't be able to fund
our inventory.
So, literally,
everything is riding on this.
We believe if we get a Shark
on board,
we can jump-start our business
and our life together.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Angela Ferendo.
And this is my fiancé,
Steve Watts.
We are co-owners
of Slyde Handboards.
We are asking for $200,000
for 15% of our company.
Watts:
So, when I was a little kid,
my mom used to take us down
to beach for the day.
And when we were down there,
we would literally try to find
anything that we could ride
a wave with,
from broken surfboards
to Frisbees,
even our flip-flops.
But our favorite
was the fast-food tray.
It wasn't until I started
traveling around the world
that I met other surfers
that did exactly the same thing.
And that's why
I started Slyde.
Wave-riding boards
that literally fit
in the palm of your hand.
Now we're gonna show you
a video so you can see
sliders all over the world
having fun
on their Slyde handboard.
♪♪
-Cool.
-So, who wants to join us
in making Slyde
a global name brand?
But before you answer
that question,
we have some gifts
for you.
Oh, cool.
-They're very cool.
-Yeah.
-Cool.
-Okay.
So, you get your own
Slyde board.
Carbon-fiber blue.
Specially designed
out for you, Lori.
Lori, this one's special
for you.
Mr. Wonderful.
Called carbon-fiber black.
And it's another
special design.
Little Mavs action.
I like it.
-Thanks, guys.
-No problem.
High five, bro.
How does it work?
I put it on.
There's a strap to --
As that wave's
coming towards you,
you feel that power,
you put your hand out,
and pretty much the board
does the rest of the work.
As apart from
if you were bodysurfing,
um, you know,
you just get that extra
bit of control
going down the wave.
How much does it cost?
That one is $199 --
the carbon fiber.
And then our average
is the $169.
How many years
have you been doing this?
We sold our first board
in 2011.
We've sold $356,000
since we started.
How about last year?
Last year was $159,000.
That's not a lot.
What have you done
year to date?
We've done
nearly $60,000.
At the end of this year,
we should do $295,000.
Angela, how much money
did you put in
when you started
the business?
We're supposed to get married
in September.
My mom had $10,000 that
she saved up for our wedding.
Actually, these boards
that you see in front of you,
-we just got.
-This is our wedding.
So, instead of the wedding,
you bought the boards?
-Yeah.
-That's committing.
So, I made an investment
in a company called Handboards.
-Yes.
And so one
of the distribution channels
we spent a lot of time with
was these independent,
very cool surf shops.
We hired a rep,
we went to distribution...
-Yeah.
-You know.
-It's tough.
-Yeah.
We're gonna be old and gray
by the time we make
any real money doing that.
Tell me your idea.
How do you blow this up quickly?
So, our plan
is to focus first
on those specialty surf --
surf stores.
Why aren't you talking
to a Target, a Walmart?
We have just recently
sent to Target.
We are -- You know,
we have to educate first.
O'Leary: Right.
I mean, we need to put --
We need the merchandising
to support the sales.
People don't know
what it is.
Greiner: Well, listen.
I think it seems
like a lot of fun,
but I don't think I'm probably
the right partner for you.
Okay.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
-Okay. Thank you.
-Okay.
Well, thank you so much.
O'Leary:
Your numbers are small.
They're small.
I mean, you're just starting
your distribution journey.
I admire that you, um,
took all of your wedding money
and put it into inventory.
It's what you got to do.
That takes a certain
surfer attitude. I get it.
But it's not for me.
But I will tell you
one thing.
I'm gonna disclose
something to you
that's very important
for this moment.
Oh, no.
I'm actually now licensed
to marry people.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh.
And I'm willing to perform
your wedding
right here
in the Shark Tank.
And so, if you two are ready,
let's do it right now.
You may not have a deal,
but you'll leave married.
Which is just as good to me.
Yeah. Um...
I'm out, guys.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
We really appreciate it.
How does your, um,
revenue break down?
More higher-end,
athletic surfers or kids?
We are 23- to 35-year-old,
mostly men.
We also have a lot of
ambassadors that are the groms.
They're the 13-year-olds
to 16-year-olds
that are, like,
really pushing the sport.
But that's my question,
really.
The more athletic
you have to be,
the higher end,
the smaller the market, right?
Right.
The more general --
So, if that was a picture
of an 8-year-old with a smile
on a little wave,
then, all of a sudden,
it becomes a surfer starter kit.
Here's the other reason I ask.
One of my "Shark Tank" companies
is Tower Paddle Board.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
And they came in doing $40,000
in sales.
They'll do at least $8 million,
if not $10 million, this year.
-Yeah.
They do not only stand-up
paddleboards,
but they do surfboards,
as well.
We're looking
for ancillary products, right?
But if it's a very,
you know, niche product,
that doesn't help them.
Kutcher:
I think that this is, like,
this sort of minimalist approach
to going and catching a wave.
Absolutely. Yeah.
You got it.
I've lugged a surfboard
out on the water,
and it's a pain
and it's heavy.
And sometimes
you're just out there
and you want to just go
in the water really quick
and grab something
and then catch a couple waves
really, really fast.
And I think this solves
that problem.
I think the biggest trick is
the balance of,
how do you get into those bigger
stores to get those sales
to that broader audience
and keep your edge?
Yeah.
And that's all about
your brand, Slyde.
-Yeah.
I just think if you go
too wide too soon,
there's a danger
it's not cool.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not opposed to going wide
and making a lot of money.
No, no. I want to go wide
and make a lot of money,
but it's just --
It really is, I think,
just about, uh, like, being
careful about how you do it.
This is so not my space.
Okay?
I'm from Iowa.
I'm like a farm kid, all right?
I have zero experience
in getting things like this
to market.
Uh, I have a really,
really large
online distribution channel
that can help market things
and do it
with the right voice.
So I would need a partner.
And if Mark would be willing
to partner with me...
-Absolutely.
-...on the deal...
I could take it
into Tower Paddle Board.
They have the infrastructure,
they have the media.
You'd walk in
right into a huge customer base.
I'd be willing
to do the deal $200,000
for 25% of the company
and split it with him.
-Yep.
-Okay.
Okay.
Well, thank you.
Thank you very much.
What's your thought
on that offer?
We don't really want to go
above 20%
because this
is all we have.
This is our future, this is --
We put everything in it.
And now you have help.
Mark's idea
about distribution online...
Yep.
...we have a pipeline
that we can market this to
online, right?
You're actually doing
direct consumer marketing.
We can target demographics
on Facebook.
I mean, I can target
like right down to the age range
that you'd want to nail --
-Your groms...
-Yeah.
...I can nail them,
like, direct on.
And I can help you build out
a Facebook marketing strategy
on your online retail
in a way that nobody can do.
If you walk away,
you're gonna think to yourself,
"Golly, that 5%,
was it really that important?"
Narrator:
Two sharks are out.
Steve and Angela
have one offer on the table --
$200,000 for 25%
from Mark and Ashton
for their handboard company,
Slyde.
We don't really want to go
above 20%.
If you walk away,
you're gonna think to yourself,
"Golly, that 5%,
was it really that important?"
Do you want to hear
if he has an offer or not?
In life, sometimes looking
at options is not a bad idea.
We're talking about 5%.
We know.
We understand.
Robert, are you there at 20%?
That's the question.
I've made a lot of mistakes
with Handboards.
We've painfully learned
the market.
You've got to build
with the right stores,
you've got to be authentic,
and then you go wide.
He hasn't learned
from his mistakes.
-When we --
-5% --
-Let's hear his offer.
-5% is a lot to give up,
because over time, it's gonna
be worth a lot of money.
This is cool
'cause you're cool.
Ashton,
let him get his offer out.
This is cool.
Why would I want him
to get his offer out?
Your counter
was $200,000 for 20%.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, guys, while he's deciding,
let me just say this.
It's not about 5%.
You're getting
Tower Paddle Board,
you're getting me,
and you're getting Ashton.
And you're arguing
about 5%?
You keep saying
let him get his offer out,
but he keeps ho-humming
on his offer.
I just don't think
this is an add-on product
to Tower Paddle Boards.
-It's not an add-on product.
-It's a key product.
-Exactly. Thank you.
Slyde is a product
in and of itself.
But why not use the resources
of an existing asset...
That has the distribution.
We're one of 20 partners
on Amazon
that get front-page
presentation.
You're not saying
that we have to do that, right?
No.
You'll have your choice, right?
It's your call.
You can get the help or you
can get the sales support.
This is getting
really frustrating.
Here's what I'll do
for you.
I'll do the $200,000 for 15%,
which is what you offered,
and I'll marry you.
'Cause I'm tired
of listening to this.
Right, because this
is your brand,
all day, right here.
That's your brand all day long.
You need money
to do your own thing.
Angela, I'll give you
the $200,000 for 15%.
So, Angela, You have
three offers on the table.
What are you going to do?
Okay.
We value everyone here so much.
This is our third year
trying to get on the show.
-Wow.
-Third time lucky.
Third time.
So, we know, though,
that having more than one Shark
means a lot.
So...
Mark and Ashton,
if you will do 20%,
you have a deal.
Make it 22%
and you have a deal.
-Done.
-Deal.
[ Sighs, laughs ]
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-Congrats, big guy.
-This is a great deal.
-It's exciting.
-I'm so excited.
-This is awesome.
-We are, too.
This is amazing,
and the design is incredible.
-Thank you.
It's gonna be exciting.
I will not marry you.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
That's who we wanted.
♪ I like to win,
I like to win ♪